بالنسبة إلى كاثي شتاينبرغ ، فإن تاريخ عائلي للإصابة
بأمراض القلب والأوعية
الدموية جعلها تقلق بشأن
صحة قلبها
، جانب والدتي من العائلة ،
كل شخص يعاني من
أمراض القلب ،
لذا استشرت طبيب القلب الوقائي في
وقت مبكر
الذي أوصى بتبني عادات
معينة للحفاظ على القلب
أكل صحي ، حافظ على نشاطك ، اشرب
الماء ،
احصل على نوم جيد ليلاً ، قلل من
إجهادك ، أخبرها الطبيب أن
تضيف سلاحًا آخر إلى ترسانتها
، جرعة منخفضة من الأسبرين ، فهي تقلل
من خطر الإصابة بالسكتة الدماغية والنوبات القلبية
إذا كنت تعاني من ضيق في الشرايين.
تدفق الدم من خلال
الأشخاص الأفضل الذين تقل أعمارهم عن 50 عامًا أو أكبر من 70 عامًا
ليسوا مرشحين جيدين لتناول
الأسبرين يوميًا ، يجب عليهم إجراء محادثة
مع طبيبهم حول
الأسبرين.الآثار الجانبية الأكثر شيوعًا لهذه
الجرعة اليومية هي النزيف الزائد
والارتجاع الحمضي الذي لا أفعله.  لا أمارس الرياضة بشكل
كافٍ ولا أراقب وزني بدرجة كافية ، لكنني على
الأقل أتناول الأسبرين
والشيء الآخر الذي توصي به.
في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا هولي فيفرر